I was just looking on the discussion
boards on the Khan Academy Facebook page
and but Denny put up this problem asking
for it to be solved and it seems like a
problem of general interest
it's the indefinite integral of two to
the natural log of x over everything
over X DX and on the message board a
beacon also put up a solution and it is
the correct solution but I thought this
was of general interest so I'll I'll
make a quick video on it so the first
thing when you see an integral like this
is you say hey you know I have this
natural log of X up in the in the
numerator and you know what where do I
start and the first thing that should
maybe pop out of you is that this is the
same thing as the integral of 1 over X
times 2 to the natural log of X DX and
so you have an expression here or it's
kind of part of our larger function and
you have its derivative right we know
that the derivative let me write over
here we know that the derivative with
respect to X of the natural log of X is
equal to 1 over X so we have some
expression and we have its derivative
which tells us that we can use
u-substitution sometimes you can do it
in your head but this problem it's still
not trivial to do it in your head so
let's make the substitution let's
substitute this right here with a u so
let's do that so if you define u and it
doesn't have to be you it's just that's
the convention it's called u
substitution it could have been s
substitution for all we care but let's
say U is equal to the natural log of X
and then D u DX the derivative of U with
respect to X of course is equal to 1
over X or just the differential D u D U
if we just multiply both sides by DX is
equal to 1 over X DX so let's make our
substitution this is our integral so
this will be equal to the indefinite
integral or the antiderivative of 2 to
the now u so 2 to the U times 1 over X
DX now what is 1 over X DX
that's just D u so this term times that
term is just our D U
let me do it in a different color one
over x times DX is just equal to D U
that's just equal to that thing right
there now this still doesn't look like
an easy integral although it's gotten
simplified a good bit and to solve that
you know whenever I see the my my it be
the variable that I'm integrating
against in the exponent you know we
don't have any easy exponent rules here
the only time that the only thing that
I'm familiar with where I have my X or
my my variable that I'm integrating
against in my exponent is the case of e
to the X we know that the integral of e
to the X DX is equal to e to the X plus
C so if I could somehow turn this into
some variation of e to the X maybe or e
to the U maybe I can make this integral
a little bit more tractable so let's see
how can we redefine how can we redefine
this right here well 2 2 is equal to
what 2 is the same thing as e to the
natural log of 2 right the natural log
of 2 is the power you have to raise 2 to
get you have to raise e to to get 2 so
if you raise e to that power you're of
course going to get two this is actually
the definition of really the natural log
you raise e to the natural log two
you're going to get two so let's rewrite
this using this I guess we could call
this this rewrite or this I don't to
call it quite a substitution it's just a
different way of writing the number two
so this will be equal to this will be
equal to instead of writing the number
two I could write e to the natural log
of two and all of that to the you d u
and now what is this equal to well well
if I take something to an exponent and
then to another exponent this is the
same thing as taking my base to the
product of those exponents so this is
equal to this is let me switch colors
this is equal to the integral of e to
the u e to the let me write it this way
e to the natural log of two
e to the natural log of two times you
I'm just multiplying these two exponents
if I raise something to something then
raise it again we know from our exponent
rules that is just the product of those
two exponents d u now this is just a
constant factor right here this could be
you know this could just be some number
and we could use a calculator to figure
out what this is you know we could set
this equal to a but we know in general
that the integral this is pretty
straightforward we've now put it in this
form the antiderivative of e to the a
you D U is just 1 over a e to the a u
this comes from this definition up here
and of course plus C and the chain rule
if we take the derivative of this we
take the derivative of the inside which
is just going to be a we multiply that
times the 1 over a it cancels out and
we're just left with E to the au so this
definitely works out so the
antiderivative of this thing right here
is going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to 1 over our a
it's going to be one of our constant
term 1 over the natural log of 2 times
our whole expression e E and I'm going
to do something I'm just going to you
know I could write this is just some
number times U so I can write it as u
times some number and I'm just doing
that to put it in a form that might help
us simplify it a little bit so it's e to
the U times the natural log of 2 right
all I did is I swapped this order I
could have written this as e to the
natural log of 2 times u I'm just you
know this is an a a times U is the same
thing as u times a plus C so this is our
answer but we have to kind of reverse
substitute before we can feel satisfied
that we've taken the antiderivative with
respect to X but before I do that let's
see if I can simplify this a little bit
what is if I have just from our natural
log properties or our logarithm a times
the natural log of B we know this is the
same thing as the natural log of B to
the a let me draw a line here right that
this becomes the exponent on whatever
we're taking the natural log of so you
let me write this here u times the
natural log of 2 is the same thing as
the natural log of 2 to the U so we can
rewrite our antiderivative
as being equal to 1 over the natural log
of 2 that's just that part here times e
to the this can be rewritten based on
this logarithm property as the natural
log of 2 to the U and of course we still
have our plus C there now what is e
raised to the natural log of 2 to the U
the natural log of 2 to the U is the
power that you have to raise e to to get
to 2 to the U right by definition so if
we raise e to that power what are we
going to get we're going to get 2 to the
U so this is going to be equal to 1 over
the natural log of 2 this simplifies to
just 2 to the U I drew it up here that
the natural log a I could just write in
general terms let me do it up here and
maybe I'm beating a dead horse but I can
in general write any number a is being
equal to e to the natural log of a this
is the exponent you have to raise e to
to get a if you raise e to that you're
going to get a so e to the natural log
of 2 to the U that's just 2 to the U and
then I have my plus C of course and now
we can reverse substitute what did we
set u equal to we defined you up here is
equal to the natural log of X so let's
just reverse substitute right here and
so the answer to our original equation
your answer to let me write it here
because it's satisfying when you see it
to this kind of fairly fairly convoluted
looking antiderivative problem 2 to the
natural log of x over X DX we now find
is equal to we just replace U with
natural log of x because that was our
substitution 1 over the natural log of 2
times 2 to the natural log of X plus C
and we're done this isn't in the
denominator the way I wrote it might
look a little ambiguous and we're done
and that was a pretty neat problem so
thanks thanks to bud for for posting
that